croyez-vous françois truffaut que les
enfants de 1976 sont bien différents de
ceux de l'époque des 400 coups oui
nettement nettement dans l'ensemble il
me semble plus heureux plus en harmonie
avec la vie incroyablement informé donc
plus impatients aussi d'entrer dans la
vie a dû vous fait penser un petit peu
un maître d'école
je ne sais pas il ya souvent dans mes
films quelque chose d'un aspect
didactique mais enfin j'ai eu des études
vraiment très chaotique même arrêté très
tôt
je vois probablement jeu sacralise un
peu la fonction de maître d'école la
fonction pédagogique à cause de ça je
n'aimerais pas donner des leçons des
courges et mieux faire le film dans mon
coin et les maîtresses prévision des
dates l'importance du 15e au xviiie
siècle phalippou 1572 le massacre d'où
sont partis les ouïes 1610 loïc 1,1548
traité nous est dit dans ce deuxième
concert bien qu'à la gueule 1685 8,14
euros qu'évidement 1763 paris via le
cloud le clou excuse moi de te réveiller
soit là complètement hagard sais pas ce
que ça veut dire avoir l'air à gafsa à
voir les regards est exactement comme
toi en ce moment à l'espace ont un autre
voyons jal à 1492 de cours relevé rich
1515 françois 1er vainqueur à marignan
oui c'est pas mal non ça souffle et des
mousses au 1185 et bien les bosses où tu
m'entends pédoussaut de vous s'il te
plaît desmouceaux c'est par ici que ça
se passe
regardez moi je comprends regarde-moi
regarde-moi par ici mais enfin les
moutons tués sous quoi tu n'as pas la
question
non
c'est vrai que la compagnie des enfants
me plaît énormément je m'amuse toujours
avec eux et je fais en sorte qu'ils
s'amusent avec moi et aussi en tant que
cinéaste de les filmer c'est une chose
qui ne me lasse pas donc ce que vous
avez fait avec ce film peut-être que
d'autres n'auraient pas pu le faire
c'est une affaire de personne à personne
ah oui parce que on ne filme que ce
qu'on aime ça c'est sûr on ne fume bien
que ce qu'on aime il faut s'intéresser
très spécial c'est pas du tout le même
travail qu'un film d'adultes dans une
dernière question si vous voulez est ce
que vous aimeriez être en 1976 non parce
que c'est une supposition je ne peux pas
je ne peux pas suivre
moi j'ai eu une enfance très
intéressante parce que la période de
l'occupation la libération tout ça ça ne
l'a fait de quelque chose de très
mouvementée qui nous oblige à nous
débrouiller voyez alors je ne
enfin j'ai pas de regret non mais je
n'aimerais pas non plus être enfants
aujourd'hui non je peux pas non je peux
pas c'est une hypothèse mais je ne peux
pas l'envisager
vous êtes bien adultes vient bien bien
je suis bien à faire des films voix oui
j'aime faire des films de françois
truffaut vous êtes nouveau de l'aide
non je ne peux pas dire ça jésus et non
jeu j'aime le cinéma et c'est ma vie